[Musica]
che cosa resta dell'umano che cosa
significa rimanere esseri umani e che
cosa significa vivere o non vivere in
una dimensione che è tra le due
classiche distinzioni del riflessione
scientifica filosofica e culturale
dell'occidente cioè la natura e la
cultura ormai superate sicuramente ma
ancora oggetto di princi nelle due
principali famiglie di discipline
scientifiche e che cosa significa questo
nell'età cibernetica cioè nell'età
dominata da quella scienza nocchiera che
nov herdener il suo fondatore aveva
definito la scienza del controllo e
della comunicazione nell'animale e nella
macchina se consideriamo che animale
significa qualcosa di animato e la
macchina o macchina dal latino è un
congegno che si muove nel mondo
forse possiamo iniziare a capire ciò a
cui mi riferisco e adesso proprio perché
sarà un pendolo continuo fra le scienze
dure e le scienze morbide
vi invito a tenere nella memoria
dell'immaginario questa immagine è
tratta da un film ex machina di cui non
vi farò lo sport e naturalmente ma che
cifra già vedere una creatura
artificiale chiaramente macchinica
contratti femminili che si confronta
attraverso un vetro con un essere umano
in carne ed ossa da di genere maschile e
questo significa già essere in un
setting di un test particolare di cui
parleremo e tenendo questa immagine
possiamo dire che cosa resta dell'umano
nell'età cibernetica
accorpando il titolo è il sottotitolo
quando tenendo appunto questo aspetto
sullo sfondo possiamo dire fino a che
punto possiamo venir modificati dalle
tecnologie rimanendo umani e non potrò
darvi risposte solo porle alcune basi
allora volta articolate al loro interno
e la grande riflessione di oggi si muove
o diciamo è innervata da queste due
coppie di concetti post umano come
condizione transumano come condizione
alternativa e le rispettive filosofie
posto malissimo e transumanesimo e
queste due coppie in ogni caso si
confrontano con la relazione fra umano e
ma chi li co op appunto macchi nico se
vogliamo lasciare l'origine latina e se
arriverà per gradi
alla fine a questa riflessione passando
per esperienze cognizioni ed emozioni
che sicuramente ci caratterizzano come
umani quindi ripensare l'umana va
significa anche utilizzare da un lato
tutto quello che la cultura alta e bassa
le immagini fisse e in movimento
dell'immaginario globale dai romanzi ai
comics manga agli anime in una visione
anche interculturale ci permette di
capire questa realtà suo genere che la
realtà sociale della cultura e che direi
che nessun altro meglio di un grande
scrittore di teorico come philip dick ha
chiamato la realtà è quella che rimane
quando abbiamo smesso di crederci questa
realtà sociale ris della cultura e della
società ci può aiutare a capire a
decifrare con le funzioni
dell'immaginario alcuni aspetti di
questa trasmigrazione adesso passiamo al
polo delle scienze e vediamo come gli
stessi acronimi cioè quei nomi che
contengono tutti gli iniziali dei
significati che le contengono
addirittura nelle scene
scienze della vita ma anche nella
bionica in particolare nelle pratiche
abilitative prosthetic e dimostrano che
esiste una necessità già all'interno
delle scienze dure di una fortissima
apertura interdisciplinare proprio
perché gli aspetti dell'umano che
vengono curati e riabilitati potenziati
come vedete spaziano da genetica
robotica information technology
nanotechnology oppure nanotechnology
information technology and computer
science
quindi vediamo che la sfaccettatura di
questa apertura di nuove dimensioni sia
vista già dalle scienze che sono ormai
far parte della nostra realtà quotidiana
e quindi tornando al pendono dalla parte
dell'immaginario questi nuovi ambiti
ripeto di cura riabilitazione
potenziamento che ci aprono le scienze
come stanno invece con quei sogni e gli
incubi dell'immaginario fantascientifico
in cui il non morto
ciò che non vive che non è nato e tutta
la fantasmagorica classificazione dei
non nati da donna come il grande
visionario ingegnere tagliasco prendendo
da shakespeare aveva chiamato tutta
quella serie di creature artificiali
ibride che continuano ad animare o a
inquietare i nostri sogni i nostri
incubi partendo dai dal gol e dal più
antico antropoide tellurico artificiale
fino appunto ai cyborg replicante e
appunto agli androidi ginoide e come
influenzano queste figurazioni l'idea
che abbiamo di ciò che è umano e
soprattutto l'idea di come ci dobbiamo
comportare perché le macchine che sono
senzienti calcolati i reagenti sono lo
specchio della nostra umanità oggi e ci
pongono questi
etiche da e pragmatiche fondamentali per
cui ritorniamo alla nostra ginoide
quindi vi ho detto che l'android e
femminile si chiama ginoide in questo
caso è una creatura molto curiosa una
scienziata che ha rovesciato e
trasformato il setting del suo in test
perché come vedete è lei che interroga
l'umano e soprattutto in totale
trasparenza non vi ha più possibilità di
essere ingannati
il punto è che domandarsi che cosa
significa essere umano se io mi
considero non ancora abbastanza umana
perché in questo proprio in questa trama
vedremo che la ginoide arriva ad avere
caratteri sempre più femminili e sempre
più mimetici durante tutto il percorso
ma l'interrogativo che ci pone è questo
tipo che cosa vuol dire essere umano non
vi è niente di più umano dalla volontà
di sopravvivere di vivere degnamente
oppure di queste due proposizioni le
possiamo considerare sicuramente ancora
coordinate ma disgiuntiva quindi la
prima opzione non è non vi è niente di
più mano che la volontà di sopravvivere
non ci riporta alle origini che ci
legano a tutti gli esseri animati e che
quindi ci riconducono una visione
darwiniano evoluzionistica conflittuale
della relazione fra le specie e tra ciò
che è umano e fra ciò che non lo è non è
piuttosto la volontà di vivere
degnamente quello che ci rende umani e
che quindi permette anche a noi di fare
un salto nell'apprendimento etico
diventare meglio di ciò che siamo senza
necessariamente aver bisogno di una
rinascita morale del genere umano
semplicemente mettere a frutto le
potenzialità e le risorse
forse etiche che già possediamo e quindi
le nuove sfide di una bio robotico
diciamo etica diciamo pure di una
roboetica possono essere di nuovo
espresse in domande essere umano
significa essere puro dal punto di vista
della ripresa de sangre cioè vuol dire
essere nato o nata da donna secondo
metodi naturali oppure essere umano
equivale a possedere esercitare
l'abilità di essere responsabile di fare
scelte e di assumersi responsabilità di
tali scelte e quindi queste nuove
creature fanno già parte anche se in
forma di esperimento mentale nella nuova
frontiera dell'etica naturalmente io
rispondo a con un no alla prima domanda
rispondo un sì a tutte le altre
e quale sarebbe la soluzione dal punto
di vista umano
potremmo riformulare l'imperativo etico
di count adeguandolo alla nuova
relazione con gli esseri ibridi e
artificiali e dire appunto che essere
umano vuol dire agisci in modo da
trattare tutti questi esseri macchina
lumachini c
almeno il via di principio non soltanto
come strumenti non soltanto come mezzi
ma anche come figli dentro un orizzonte
intramondana dentro una dimensione più
inclusiva e non più antropocentrica dal
punto di vista invece della macchina ex
machina potremmo vedere che potremmo
francamente riprendere la legge 0 di
isaac asimov un grande di nuovo
scienziato e scrittore di fantascienza
che chiama con la legge 0 una massima
fondamentale un robot ossia un
intelligenza una creatura capace di
sentire rispondere e di agire nel mondo
non deve recare in nessun modo danno
all'essere umano né permettere per
omissione che venga arrecato danno
adesso e quindi ritorniamo con
un'accentuazione positiva sulla slides
che parlava di post umano post umanesimo
contrapposto al trancio mano il
transumanesimo perché perché soltanto la
legge 0 ci permette di fare una cosa
fondamentale cioè di togliere
l'etichetta di mostruosità o di essere
fonte di repulsione
a tutto ciò che non è biologicamente
puro e ci mette al sicuro dal ritorno
strisciante del razzismo e della volontà
di discriminazione nei confronti di
nuove entità
si riporta di nuovo al dilemma di dover
rifuggire dal razzismo in quanto un male
latente nella nostra condizione umana
post umano ci permette entrato di
connettere il passato il presente e il
futuro perché di radici del post umano
appunto le abbiamo trovate dal gol in
tutte le culture anche non occidentali
facendo riferimento anche a quelle forme
di sapienza e di conoscenza che sono
l'animismo lo shintoismo e tutte le
altre riflessioni non monoteistiche
oppure accanto a quelle monoteistiche
che permettono di aprire una via ad
inclusione di tutti gli esseri viventi e
non viventi umani e normali fino
addirittura ad includere la dimensione
della materialità nel suo più ampio
complesso quindi il post umanesimo è la
corrispondente concezione di una
costellazione di una condizione che può
essere considerata un passato carico di
futuro
a differenza di questo il trans umano è
una condizione anch'essa
definita dal transumanesimo tramite
ideale definitivo ed ultimo del main
applausi dello scaricamento del la mente
e quindi dell'abbandono del corpo della
radicale smaterializzazione se vogliamo
di un futuro di pura razionalità in cui
le relazioni saranno soltanto fra puri s
i materiali abbandonando la grande
dimensione che ci fa non solo esseri
umani ma ci fa essere relazionali perché
senza il corpo senza la fondamentale di
definizione dell'orientamento del tempo
e dello spazio e dell'assunzione di
responsabilità che la corporeità di
qualunque tipo essa sia c.da perdiamo
moltissimo e se ricordiamo di nuovo le
scienze di cui io ho parlato o le altre
tipologie di con nubi interdisciplinari
di scienze che si occupano di cura
riabilitazione potenziamento quando ci
spostiamo sul potenziamento vediamo che
le nuove discipline fanno capire che non
potremo mai eliminare la vulnerabilità
non solo perché è inevitabile che noi
saremo costretti a dover riconfigurare
nuove vulnerabilità come l'esempio del
tallone di achille ci ricorda ma anche
perché la vulnerabilità è anche una
dimensione di apertura di nuova
possibilità di nuovi futuri e di nuovo
il posto umano come condizione e questo
ma nesimo come riflessione filosofica c
a volte anche da un'altra cosa che non
ci sono futuri iscritti vi sono tante
possibili configurazioni di questa nuova
dimensione e soprattutto c è il vita non
cadere nella trappola del dualismo tra
ottimisti o pessimisti i tecnofili ax e
invece i nemici della tecnologia
in realtà siamo in un
la serie di tradizioni nascoste che ci
rendono possibili nuovi futuri vi faccio
ancora due esempi uno da manovre cir
porto in cui vedete che è possibile
avere versioni diverse per gli
impercettibili elementi del futuro che
quindi si realizzerà diversamente e
anche le scienze ci dicono che la più
perfetta equazione cambiano i risultati
al momento in cui si modifichino ampie
di un micro le condizioni di partenza
quindi possibili futuri alternativi ci
sono davanti
andiamo oltre il determinismo grazie
[Applauso]